we start with breaking news sky news
understands that the whole of
nottinghamshire
will go into tier 3 lockdown on
friday morning nottingham city
brookstowe
gedling and rushcliff council areas had
already been preparing to enter
tier three at midnight tonight instead
the entire county will go into the
highest restrictions
together on friday well let's cross
live to westminster and our political
correspondent kate mccann
uh kate i suppose the government's done
this in order to ease confusion
for those in that part of the world i
think that's been the general aim here
is to make sure that the whole county
goes into the same tier
tier three at the same time and of
course as you said there some areas had
been expecting this perhaps a little
earlier than
friday at midnight but now the whole
county will move into that much more
stricter
lockdown measure together as one and the
local mps have generally welcomed it
there had been some suggestion that
hospitals in nottinghamshire
had had to cancel some cancer operations
and that of course had led to
increased levels of concern about rising
infections in fact the infection rate in
nottinghamshire has
on the whole come down from the peak
where it was around seven days ago but
still
running at quite a high level and some
pretty big concerns about what happens
if it doesn't
go lower than where it is now so clearly
tier three
the most strict tier of the government's
new system
is where ministers feel is appropriate
at the moment that of course means that
people cannot socialize in the ways that
they were before that some places will
be closed pubs and restaurants for
example can't open
unless they're serving a substantial
meal what it will mean for people though
living there
is a big change in their way of life and
of course there is a whole debate now
about how areas can move out of these
tiered systems
and what kind of things the government
is looking at to reduce restrictions on
people's lives
for the moment though at that point in
time the whole of the county of
nottinghamshire will move into tier
three together
at the end of this week